I have stage 4 prostate cancer. What would you recommend? Well, that's kind of a
loaded question because I don't have like a protocol for or stage 4 prostate
cancer. So we do cheek swab testing for our cancer patients and then we make
recommendations based on that. And you could have two twin brothers with
prostate cancer and their recommendations could be completely different because
everybody's unique. But in general, what should a person do with a prostate
cancer? Well, you should do some things that decrease inflammation. But
it partly depends on what else you're doing from a standard of care perspective.
If you're doing loop run or an energy deprivation therapy, everybody do an
energy deprivation therapy, which is if you're going to follow standards of
care with prostate cancer, it's just what everybody's going to be in that kind of
memory. You should be doing andrographis. Andrographis is an herb, and everybody
doing energy deprivation therapy should be own. Also, EGCG, which is the
Catechin from Green T extract. Everybody that's doing energy deprivation therapy
should be on that. Now historically, loop run, energy deprivation therapy, will
reduce a person's PSA. So if you have PSA, if 31, or 12, or 700, it will
typically bring that PSA down. It will give you some comfort that may have my PSA
dropped in half after I started loop run. But there's question to whether it
actually decreases the growth of the cancer product. So if you're
have to be on loop run, you want it to work as long as possible. The other issue
with loop run has been that it tends to work for a period of time, maybe a year,
maybe two years, maybe four years, and then it just doesn't seem to work. Well,
studies have shown that andrographis and Green T extract, EGCG, increase the
time that that that drug will work. If you're going to be on it, you want it to
work as long as possible. Even if you're going to go off and beat those two
different nutritional products, can hold the benefits of that for a longer period
of time, relatively inexpensive thing to do. If you go to cuttersclinic.com and
search cancer and search prostate cancer, I have lots of articles on prostate
cancer with some different suggestions in it as well. But understand, everybody in
our clinic is treated as an individual. So I'd highly recommend you do a case
review, we talk about it, we talk about food and possible chicks.